I am I on Carl I just want to make sure
that we're that we're recording okay
we're going all right good hey welcome
to it welcome to the 12th annual
Christmas tree lecture lecture I meant
to give a year ago but unfortunately i
was i'm able to make it but better late
than never and i got a lot of stuff to
tell you about today that i think is
really cool and and I want you to
interrupt me oh you know as soon as you
don't understand something because I
want to I want to make sure that that
you're that you're getting it too
because you know I waited a year to give
this lecture so I so I'm not you know
I'm I'm not as well prepared as I would
have been a year ago now last year was
the year that this little book was
published art of computer programming
volume for fascicle for this is just you
know these art is about 120 120 pages
that are some day going to be in volume
for the Artic computer program and it's
all about trees and you know every year
my tradition is Bennett I to give a
lecture about what's the greatest thing
I learned about trees during the year
well this is the greatest thing I
learned about trees last year but but in
this book actually I want to mention it
now because it makes a marvelous
Christmas present you know if somebody
asks you what you want for one for
christmas because it in here it contains
that the stuff that i talked about in
many of these other lectures in this
series over the years that when I first
discussed them in fact there's even none
there's even something called the
Christmas tree pattern well
on this page here is the Christmas tree
pattern of order agents and that was my
lecture I don't know four years ago and
lots of other things I talked about in
this series come up in the connection of
this book where it's really you know in
my humble opinion the best treatment
ever of of the subject of trees a
computer science way wise and anyway
there's a lot of stuff in here that you
won't find any other other books so
there it is and today however is
something that that doesn't go in the
book except in part but it's but I I
think you'll you'll see why I'm excited
about once I get into the topic now my
title was pleased rivers and RNA and
those of you who've been coming to these
lectures know that I'll you know that
I'll do anything like to get an audience
and make up a catchy title so if you're
here to you know to you know with the
idea that i'm going to solve one of the
great problems of human health or
something bye bye what i tell you today
i'm sorry this is pretty much a pure
math lecture today it's a topic income
notorious that and mathematics but my
motivation is that that we found a
mathematical concept that's discussed by
people in many different parts of this
campus and in fact it's appropriate that
that i'm given a lecture here in this in
skilling auditorium right next to the
geology building because the whole story
started when some geologists were we're
trying to find nice mathematical models
of river systems and in 1945 man named
Horton was the first to publish this
mathematical model which is which arose
in in
the connections that I'm going to be
sure i'll be showing you now well let me
show you actually what what Horton see I
think I found his so that's that's
rivers of well I can show you the
illustration from Hortons article
bulletin of the of the geological
society of america 1945 he's taking a
riverbed a river basin in georgia and
and and he he has this this idea that is
that you take all the little the the
littlest starts the rivers and you call
them rivers of order 1 and then when
there's a junction between two rivers of
order one you're supposed to get a river
of order 2 and then when there's one
that when a 2 joins up with the one it
still stays at two but if a to meet satu
then it becomes a three and four three
meats of one or two it stays at three
but if the three meets another three it
becomes a four and so so he sort of goes
it goes on and does his buddy did you
didn't do it in the way that that was
cleaned up later because after after
after the whole thing was funny he's got
this big you know Hiwassee River and
then he decides well now let me see you
know I'll go look at this river and see
which where it really originated and he
brings this for back into the until one
of these ones is actually called a for
back here and said this is really the
source of the Hiwassee River know
mathematically we know stop doing that
and a sequel to this paper came out in
in the same journal in 1952 and where
where the man said
and this author was was named stroller
and he said let's not let's not use this
let's let's not make the model more
complicated that where we have to go
back and look look at the angle in which
rivers join up with each other anything
we just keep this this idea that if that
we start out with ones and then when to
one's meet they form a 2 and so on and a
lot of what I tell you today I learned
from the man I met last year a extremely
interesting mathematician and named vino
and this is a preprint of a paper he
published in 2002 I had been wanting to
meet him for a long time and finally I
got it we happen to both be at a
workshop in Sweden for a couple of weeks
and we got to work together and and I
I've been wondering you know a lot of a
lot of things he writes I are in
preprints and then he never did then
never come out in print what turns out
he's like he's a very colorful character
bon vivant mathematics is just one of
the many interests in his life I have no
idea how many other are they kept
learning more about him every day but
but among other things he has he owns a
lots of land in Bordeaux and an attend
and has lots and lots of of our
vineyards and and so he's a wine grower
and connoisseur I think he also is a
local mayor or something in his in his
village and and you know I I thought I
was wondering about half of his papers
go bye-bye gxv know and half of them go
x XG you know and I always try to have
my book correct and I didn't know what
his record is what his real name was so
he wrote it out for me here Jeremy shell
francois-xavier you know and and people
call him sorry
and so here he signs some of his papers
with you know names in sort of random
order now now he but but I can we zoom
in on this suck how close can you get it
go to the max on this this is he drew
this of a river network in the
neighborhood of Bordeaux week where he
lives and I you can see some of these
numbers on here so he's he's found the
the Hortense trawler number now of this
river system and you see how it builds
up to tues here and then then to tues
come together and make a three and then
eventually we get to a fact 25 coming
together and this at the end EST is the
big river 6 okay now computer scientists
Horton installer did their work in the
40s and 50s computer scientists weren't
born yet but but as soon as we started
writing compilers in the early 60s we
came across the same concept but in
another another disguise we had a
problem of trying to write compilers and
the question was how many registers do
you need to evaluate an arithmetic
expression so if you have an expression
like you know a a times B plus C you can
do that in one in one register I mean if
you put a times B that that goes into
that goes into register and then you can
add see well depending on your model of
computation but if you but if you if you
have to add a plus B type a times B plus
C times D you've got two things that
each need one register for them before
you can do the adding and so it's going
to take you two registers you could have
one register for a times B and one
register for C times D and so we you
know we ran across this so you take an
arithmetic expression and it's really
it's really a binary tree formed out of
binary operators and when when a
three register expression is met by a to
register expression you can do it in
three registers because you can do the
to register I'm sorry do the three
registers our expression first and then
use it you know put you put in one of
your registers and then you've got two
registers to do the other one and then
you can add and you're going to use
three to register but if you got a three
register expression with a free register
expression this is order for you got it
you got to go to fourth so we had the we
had this concept of the the register
number for a binary tree for evaluating
a binary 20 and it was in that context
that mathematician started studying the
question if somebody gives you a random
binary tree how many registers are you
going to need you know how common is it
that that you that you can get by with
just a few registers to evaluate an
expression and it wasn't it I think we
know is the guy who discovered somehow
that that these these geologists had
already come up with the equivalent
concept when you're studying rivers know
now well I'm talking about vino and my
book i want to show you an illustration
that I like here because he and some and
some friends of his realize that you
could also use this for drawing trees
computer scientist you would like to
like to make pictures of a binary trees
and and he realized that if you that
that if you've got this this Hortense
trawler number on a tree it helps you
make draw the tree in a way that looks
realistic so so so here I I've got these
these pictures where where I start out
and the leaves are just you know simple
things of order 1 and then when two
leaves come together we get a stem
that's a little bit bigger and two of
these stems of order to join up to get a
thicker stem and so you can you can make
a nice way to create
but biological looking trees from your
computer trees with a very simple thing
which is explained here in exercise 124
on page 47 of this wonderful book and it
says and here it says you know you want
to choose the thick the width and the
wick the width here is 3 plus the order
so if you have a something of order K
you make it 3 plus KY you make the
length the height of it 18k and then if
you have two things coming together you
you bring them in at 30 degree angles or
you know it's just a function of the
order of things as to how you join
things up and and if you have a if you
have like a three tree meeting up with a
4-3 then then you have a function that
says well how much should you bend for
the four branch and how much should you
bend for the three branch and here's a
formula that that seems to work nicely
and so I got these i got these pictures
of trees and and and vino and three
other causes published in the siggraph
proceedings from 1989 this picture of
some trees that they it was in color in
the in the actual proceedings but you
know they they make up these trees with
their mathematical model and and you
know they look like pretty much like a
photograph and you have different
versions that they that they got now
here in fact here i took a random binary
tree you know all with a hundred notes
all all trees binary trees of 100 nodes
equally likely and if you take a random
one it tends to look like this you know
pretty much like a vine growing this on
the other hand if you take a random
binary search tree so so instead of
saying that all binary trees are equally
likely but but say instead a binary tree
gets a probability associated with how
often it occurs when you when you insert
keys one at a time according to the
standard way of
doing a binary search tree then the tree
you know be cuttin tends to be pretty
well balanced and and and it's it's it's
got you know log in now the average
distance to the leaf is about to log in
well in the in the other case it's
washing the square root of n and so
here's a example of a random binary
search tree what it looks like when you
when you draw it with this scholar
number heuristic and this is something
this is a special tree called the
Fibonacci tree which is which is a
special a special case where the
Fibonacci tree of order aight has two
branches which one of which is the
fibonacci tree of order seven and one of
the fibonacci tree of order six and and
and that it makes such a beautiful
pattern i I just love working with
computer graphics because you get left
brain right brain working together and
you can you know even your bugs look
beautiful when you're when you're when
you're doing that when you're working on
I'm graphic so ok so for computer
scientists we've got these these numbers
of both because they mean the registers
to evaluate expressions and because they
help us draw nice-looking tree now the
an amazing thing happened oh and it was
again provena was supervising a the PhD
thesis of a of a student and her name of
is beautiful I felt I gotta get it right
it's something like yeah merial rochas
all day shomal and she wrote her PhD
thesis at 1985 I think and and in the
course of doing this she discovered that
the same that that um equivalent concept
occurs in in biology for example in RNA
and that's the other part of my title
trees rivers in RNA and I and and here's
that here's the deal on on on his atty
got this out of a journal
of biochemistry from early 80s of as an
example of you know to show we got we
got basically forms huge molecules and
their planar and the end and the end the
fact that there and they don't have
loops you know the molecule doesn't
doesn't join onto itself so it's a tree
and and we can actually think of it as a
tree with you know with with many
branches and so now here's a here's a
very natural mathematical model for
dealing with with such things like huge
molecules that occur we we say that a
filament is a is a branch of a tree that
has where everybody has just one child
until we finally get a leaf that has no
children you know but then you know
maybe maybe there's another filament
over here and so anyway we let's let me
draw um a more complicated thing which
has some branching coming off here I can
go on all day and draw this but the idea
here is that we can we can take us we
can take filaments and remove them so I
chop this off and I chopped this off a
chop this huh and this and this this and
me n ish and then I'm left with well in
this case just a spine of a of these
four nodes survive here but but they
take away all the filaments but in a
more complicated case uh I would have
had more you know I would have had a
little bit of branch more more problem
here branching so so so I remove this
guy in this guy then I would have had a
branch here so so then in the second
second stage
I would remove these three filaments I
have one guy left and so there's there's
the so-called pruning order of the of a
of a large molecule or of a large a
large tree I'm saying how many times do
you have to repeat this process of
removing filaments until you get down to
the empty until you get down to the
empty fours so and and merial rochas
Moshe Saudi shema discovered the
incredible fact that the number of
forests that have pruning order k & n
nodes to them is equal to the number of
binary trees with n nodes that have
staller number K so the same thing that
occurs in this river process is is
actually occurring in here now you might
think that that's obvious because they
somehow seem a little bit like each
other but the more you look at it the
more the more amazing that that fact
occurs now and there's some good stories
that go with that but first let me think
let me give you some quantitative some
corn for a picture and and that's let's
actually start out bike but by looking
at the smallest cases the case N equals
3 is always good to go with and so I
have I have five binary trees with N
equals 3 one of them looks like this one
of them looks like this I mean a binary
tree every node has two branches one of
which might be empty I and so it could
is this way this over here and there's
like this and I could put like I could
show the empty the empty branches on the
other sides to get up anyway there are
these end and well you see that the
stroller number here is
one and then a one meets of zero and
stays a one here's a and so these are
one but here's a one meeting a one comes
up with it with a two all right so if we
look at all the at these five trees we
see that one of them has two at the root
and the other four have one at the root
and if I if I did the same thing for the
14 trees when N equals 4 it would turn
out that six of them have two at the
root and and and the other eight have
one at the room now you can't get up to
you can't get up to 3 with a binary tree
until you have a certain number of nodes
there because you got to have two twos
coming together right so the smallest
binary tree that's going to have a three
it's going to have to have two twos and
for those i have to have 21 so so i have
to have seven nodes all together before
i get to a three with in my in my
stroller number okay now all right now
so here's a table see that um so for
small in here you see when we get seven
notes there's 11 of those trees has
strong number 3 360 for 264 of them have
have one if we look at the table here
for the these numbers so some of you
will guess what this pattern is here in
the first column some people are
guessing and figure it out right these
are powers of 2 this looks like 2 to the
N minus 1 and that's these are the ones
that's that that's day one and you see
why it is because you you're going Jiggs
AG either left or right at each stage so
you got n minus 1 choices go left go
right but but never bring two ones
together gets a little more complicated
to figure out that binary trees with
staller number two
and and so on but the what if you look
at the generating function it's is Z
over 1 minus 2z the power the
coefficients of that are the powers of 2
and then you multiply that by this
generating function Z squared over 1
minus 4z put plus 2 Z squared and got
and then you get you know Z cubed over
some polynomial and that defines the
recurrence of order 3 and it's and
here's the these numbers satisfy that
recurrence and you go to the next one
you multiply by another another function
here with another polynomial in the
denominator and the product of these 3
polynomial gives you the generating
function for all binary trees with a 3
at the root and incidentally this isn't
a random polynomial here it's it's you
can you can factor it in terms of
cosines this is 1 minus 4z times cosine
squared of pi over 16 times one minus 4z
cosine squared three pi over 16 5 pi
over 16 7 pi over 16 that's why it's a
polynomial of degree 4 and that same
pattern goes on and on so people in the
1970s discovered that that d that in
order to count how many binary trees
have a certain stralla number there was
some beautiful mathematics I associated
with these with these things so as as
mr. brochure saw de shema working on a
thesis be now said why don't you look at
this at this model of the filaments and
removing filaments that is what his
friends and biology had shown him and
she discovered two to everybody's great
surprise that you got the same numbers
for that problem in other words the
number of n node forests of seven of
let's say 17 note for us which witch go
away in one remove all the filaments is
exactly 65536 and the number which take
four steps
before you are you reducing to the empty
set of 494 and so on so now so something
now whenever two rather different
problems both or not have the same
answer it's always worth while you know
saying something something what good
must be going on and to end and to and
to look a little more at the mathematics
here I got here another case of N equals
100 just so you get some idea so take
take all the the binary trees with a
hundred nodes and there's the same as
the number of forests of 100 nodes for
us aren't binary there there you know
the forest is anything that has no loops
in it and and basically that's that's
the rule a graph with with a hundred
nodes and no cycles and the this number
here which you might not recognize as 2
to the 99th power and then you know the
case where a strong number two three
four five and six so and these are of
course if you look at probabilities and
you almost always have a three or four
in the tree in a binary tree of 100
nodes you almost always get a three or
four at the root only you know you get a
five here in this case but you divide
this by the sum of the of
everything and this is like one up this
is like you know one percent of the
total and this is even smaller so it's
really tiny the probabilities but it
looks to me like might be a log normal
distribution like that you know the
number of digits in the in these in
these numbers is normal rather than the
numbers themselves so its weight
distribution tends to be concentrated on
a small number of values in in practice
and now the now the thing since there's
you know since they're it's the same
number
be nicer okay let's let's now fight and
they and they and you know they proved
that it was the same number but to say
well there must be some way to take any
any forest of n nodes and that has a
certain proof that any number K and
convert it into a into a binary tree
that has stralla number K and you know
this would be a wonder one
correspondence between all the all the
forests and all the binary trees and and
and it would preserve the stroller
number but he couldn't come they
couldn't think of any thought a lots of
ways to there's many many ways known to
to show that the number of forests of n
nodes is the number of binary trees of
EndNote but none of those seem to you
know seem to show that had that that was
doing anything anything with this so so
he decided to up to to offer a prize of
10 bottles of Bordeaux wine vintage 1982
to any mathematician who could solve
this problem and find a nice natural
wonder one correspondence between
between these two concepts and and that
and five years later d'harans I'll
burger another remarkable mathematician
from came up with a solution to this
problem and and now i have to mention
that mathematicians when they have a
one-to-one correspondence between
objects they call them they call them by
actions i I learn mathematics when by
ejection was a scary word and it wasn't
what wasn't bandied about in in in in
the popular press or anything and so I
just wanted to say that nowhere in the
art of computer programming will you
find the word by jection in fact I
translate a whole bunch of pure
mathematics into words that I think are
more or less scary or more
the more grounded somehow a little you
know I be I come to admire bro Becky and
everything over the years i hope the
group that invented these words but it
just didn't seem like me talking about
bye Jek shins and so so although people
don't realize that i actually try to
make the art of computer programming
easy to read you know I mean it's it you
know maybe I don't succeed you know at
least I get a few more readers than if I
had been using a lot of a lot of the
highest you know the the most egregious
terms so anyway I but but now here I am
working with with vino last year and and
we become so I decided okay i will write
a a paper with with projection in the
title although i'm not going to publish
it it's just it's just available on the
web but i do have this paper now called
three catalan bye Jek shins so anyway
and i'm going to talk even i'm going to
mention today throughout the next few
minutes of this lecture i'm saying
rejection rejection rejection because
because it's you know it's a mouthful to
say one to one correspondence all the
time so now here so i want to find a
correspondence between you know this
takes any any by 93 into a forest or
vice versa the inverse court come on
take a for us into a binary tree and and
it's supposed to have this property that
it that the binary three it has slipped
our number k up at the root then this
forest is going to have pruning order k
the number of times you remove blue
filaments has this has this this
characteristic now Oh before I before I
talk a little more about projection so I
want to mention one other thing because
it's an open problem that really is
almost too scandalous that it hasn't
been solved yet and and vino says that a
lot of his French friends have been have
been a
leaving their heads against the wall on
this problem although it seems like it
should be easy to solve and that is not
only to is to study this dismiss it this
pruning process the pruning order of
filaments of in detail and find out what
it does we know of according to the
theorem we know how many how many
forests are going to wind up are going
to need k steps to before they disappear
but but but let's take a look at the at
the case of for example take all the
forests with 17 notes and and and so
there's this many 129 millions of them
all have 17 notes after one pruning I I
have you know one of them has only still
has 15 knows left but you know 65536 are
already wiped out and and this many here
you know 1 1,000,000 hundred flights out
and so on have only one note left after
one pruning up and after two prunings so
so after three prunings you notice
there's a strange thing we got 40 it
ends up with 462 30 11 somehow at the
tail here now the unsub problem is what
the heck are these numbers we've got a
good formula for the generating function
method at this at the at the zero point
here but these other numbers up as far
as I know statisticians have no idea you
know what's going on as you start out
with a random forest and then you can in
you prune away filaments two times how
big is how many have you got left at
this point on the average or you know
what kind of a distribution do you have
um and it's it I don't know of any other
cognate oriole problem so simple to
describe for which the statisticians
have no good
formula 44 how you know for for the size
and not approximate or anything it's
just you know we can calculate these
numbers if n is small enough but if we
if we if we take a hundred node forest
and we and we say well what happens
after after four prunings what kind of
distribution do you get our I think we
just best notice it well try simulating
it and see what happens you know and I
don't think that even the conjecture as
to what the order of growth is of this
the reason is that after you remove the
filaments as you have at the beginning
you don't have a random forest anymore
some forests are much more likely to
occur after than others after after you
remove filaments on the first on the
first pass so that's an open problem
that if that I think deserves a lot more
advertisement around in the non French
parts of the world and maybe you know if
somebody will figure out how to how to
crack it is certainly it's certainly
something that if I had another lifetime
you didn't have to write the out of
computer program is certainly I would
like to take part in solving I you can
look at it in this way you can put a one
and on these fall out Oxford I'll show
you in a minute something thats related
to this problem so anyway these are this
is this is a fascinating unsolved
problem that text seems to me should be
solved such a simple mathematical model
what does removing filaments do okay now
by ejections there's there's two okay
let me show you like a huge number of by
actions between forests and trees and I
started out with a in in this book I
start out with a a random forest that
action
I reveal on page 80 something that it's
based on pie somehow they get to this
for us but you have but they not
supposed to it's not too obvious why why
but anyway this is this is basically
random and I end and it's you see it the
forest that because there's no loops to
it and and when I say Forester I by the
way I always mean ordered forest I
always got an order that you know if I
put this guy over here that would I
consider that a different forest I'm
considering the left to right order is
important in all these statements i make
about forests and binary being related
to binary tree now if the gutter forest
it has a bunch of trees in it i want to
i want to make that correspond to 82 a
binary tree so there's you know there's
I find one node for example I can take
the leftmost tree in the forest and I
can look at his route for example but
but anyway I could so I've got it a
forest it's got a bunch of trees in it
right and and I and then I I I find one
note I single that out for example I can
take that guy or or if I hadn't met
before I could but I could do something
now then I then I find some rule in
dividing the rest of the thing into 2
into two sub force for example i could
say take all of the all the descendants
of of this leftmost root and call that
that'll be a that'll be a forest and i
can take all of the other trees besides
the first tree and that's a fourth and
then recursively i say that this is
going to map into you know the binary
tree that you get by taking this guy a
and putting them here and then and then
I then here i put the binary tree that
corresponds to this forest and here i
put the binary tree that corresponds to
this for us which mike these might be
empty so anyway that's one one way to
get a correspondence between force and
binding between that's the natural way
in fact it turns out
I illustrated here if you if you if you
draw a link to to your left most son
left most child and and then the right
links are to the siblings so for is has
a sibling of six then the right links
would go to siblings in the left and the
left links go to the first child and you
get a very simple correspondence between
forest boundary but you could do you
could do lots of other things for
example you could say you know choose a
node well I you know I could talk I
could shoot that I have to choose I felt
some real that that that singles out one
of the nodes that i'm going to put at
the root and you know I I could say you
know if there are n trees if there are
you know can trees in the forest look at
the the the 28th one counting modulo 10
or something like this but just find
some way to single out one of the trees
and then pick one of its nose some way
or other maybe the fifth in pre order or
something choose it anyway but then
figure out a way to divide the rest in
the fourth it smells like suppose I
still choose the leftmost tree and its
root but then I could take these and I &
M before I and before I actually go
further maybe I maybe I will cyclically
permute these trees and maybe I'll flip
these left to right or something like
this then again and and then I apply my
recursive rule there's many many
different recursive rules which would
give me which would then define this
mapping from the forest to the binary
tree now it's it's a rejection means we
can go backwards because if somebody
gives me the binary tree that you got
that way then you can say okay by
induction I can I can figure out what
what force came from the left subtree
and I could figure out what forest came
from the right subtree let me up so one
left subtree I'll take its mirror image
and put it on under here and you know
take this guy put them up at the root
and and this one all secretly from you
and then I get my original forest so so
this is a this is a large family of
rejection and and zal burger who won the
one the 10 bottles of wine I came up
with a projection of that of that sort
which was and and I'll show you actually
uh let's see all right oh let me draw
that tree let me dry that forest and so
I got it has 15 nodes so it doesn't take
me too long to draw it 346 use
hexadecimal not notation here five six
seven eight nine a B is here with
hexadecimal you got to watch out the six
and B look the same but that's too bad d
e f so this is the original forest and
then zal burgers method turns out maps
into a binary tree that comes out with
one at the root and two on the left
subtree over here he's got a three then
a four be over here e d f or six be up
5789 running out of space seven gets to
a nine here and then there's an a just
group just enough room for the a there
okay so six guys look well not the main
thing is he took this for us and he
divided it up and he decided to shuffle
around some of these
some of the structure of the forest and
then he said now apply the rule
recursively to the subterranean it looks
almost like the rule that I had before
in a way because right links are still
looking a bit like siblings here but the
what's the difference is that well three
no he was a child of three here but here
it's a sibling here here here is on the
right branch instead of um instead of
being on the right branch from 60 so
anyway up now I claim that this as this
has the same staller numbers and pruning
order so let's look at the pruning order
this guy tip up here's a 1 a 1 meaning
that the birth in the first filament
these two guys go away this has a 1 and
this is a 1 this is a one but the seven
is going to be a two because it's got
its got two filaments below it here and
so 70s going to disappear in the first
pass so the six isn't going to go away
either and Abby's is a one and the D is
a 1 e and f r1 let's see is going to
stick around until until level two and
then there's going to be a three here at
the roof okay so if I if I do this
pruning of filaments everything that's a
1 here disappears and the first pass and
all the twos changed to ones and the
three change to a 2 and then the next on
the next round the twos the twos
disappear in the three you know and i'm
left with this guy now at this stage i
can i can compute the scholar number of
this one and it's 10 11 here to one's
meet each other and form a to hear i got
a 11 12 8 i'm sorry this is so sloppy 12
me to one is still a 2 A 1 is still a 2
2 meets a 2 that gives me a 3 here so i
have a1 and
three gives me a three so this has a
strong number of three at the root this
has a pruning order of three at the pet
in the forest and that's the end it I
one thing that I that I did then while I
was working with me though I had to
understand salberg like amazing by
jection and and so like being a computer
scientist I I programmed it and and I
found also which any which also always
happens when you when you program
something that there was a gap in his
crew you know it turned out that his
construction was correct but but he
could have come up with another
construction and his proof was still
said it was correct when his other
construction wouldn't have been so now
in this in this report I have a program
called zile burger that that implements
his by Jackson and also checks it by
running through all forests with a
certain number of nodes and and
converting them to binary trees
computing by brute force the stroller
number in the pruning order verify
method is saying and also I have the
inverse algorithm that goes from the
binary tree and checks that that takes
me back to the original fort and and so
this this program is you know is
unambiguous it could no hand waving or
anything the computer understands what
this construction is while I wrote the
program I noticed a curious thing that
celebrated by jection does it it not
only it not only preserves the the
pruning order to the stroller number but
it also preserves the left the left link
so so every to the left child of
everything in the in the forest remains
as as the left link in the in the in the
tree
so it so preserve it so that says for
example the number of leads of the of
the of the original forest is equal to
the number of things that have no left
leg link here so these are the number of
ether so i can say that not only can I
preserve the the pruning order but I can
also say that the number of leaves here
was equal to the number of left Lee the
number of things who have have a no left
link in the binary tree and in that span
was a surprising consequence of his of
his projection well I I don't have time
to explain his by jection to you in
detail but if anybody who's interested
can can download this it's on the web
you go to my homepage and then it says
downloadable programs and you can under
downloadable programs there they're all
three of all fell three projections that
I'm going to be talking about are there
and you can you can play play with the
thing to your heart's content you know
try it out make a change see if it's
still yes see if you can break it so on
with the with the enough information I
think to construct the formal proof that
it actually worked okay now that's
that's only the what one part of the
story why do I call this three Catalan
rejections well there was another man
who was working on the Jean from saw
this is 1984 is the number of registers
necessary to evaluate an arithmetic
expression and he noticed that this
problem which was connected to another
problem that seemed really really
different and so here's a third way in
which the same concept the straw
remember the pruning order arises in a
natural problem yet different from from
what from before
now when we have I guess that mean let
me see what's a good okay another
concept as equivalent to these binary
trees and forests is nested parentheses
and anybody who programs in lisp
language will recognize you know that
can we get this on the screen here this
yo you got left and right parenthesis
and hear that turns out there's 15 of
each and and the rule is that it they're
properly nested if the following happens
you start counting from the left to the
right and you go and you say plus one
for every left parenthesis and minus one
for every right parenthesis and at the
end you've got to come out with zero and
you can never go negative and that's
exactly the rule that that says that
that that the parenthesis it properly
nested and so I start out my books
showing how this formula nested
practices corresponds to this you know
this forest that weakness random forest
that we that we had here and I number
the parenthesis parenthesis at the top
in the right princess at the bottom and
that's how come I got the numbering of
the nose but this this nesting pattern
you find which one matches the right one
corresponds to a process of adding plus
one minus one finding up finding a path
and so here I've drawn this path for you
you know go up for the left paren system
down for two right parenthesis and then
up up up down down up up down up and so
on this gives you a a pattern which is
equivalent to the nested parentheses now
the French mathematicians call this
pattern a dyke dick path after after a
German mathematician named Ron dick who
actually never considered this concept
anywhere in his writings
and it's one of these vague vague idea
he considered something else that was
vaguely related to his to a symmetric
version of the similar problem anyway
they all mathematicians know this pass
under this name which which is
historically ridiculous because the
person who worked on it was just you
know he just had an interesting name but
he is nothing he did he worked on
another problem which which might remind
somebody of this and answer Sandberg I
was never very much interested in
history or getting dotting i's across
and teeth so anyway they call him dick
pass in my book they're just called
nested parentheses but but the point is
if you have a dick path you can
naturally to see it looks like mountains
and you can see how high is that is the
highest mountain in the dick path and so
here's a tree which has you know 15 up
steps and 15 down steps and its height
is 1 2 3 4 5 so now you can say you can
ask how many how many binary trees n
nodes or how many sorry that's the
correct nessa princess how many dick
paths of with with you know pairs of n
pairs of parentheses have a certain
height and for example you know the if
there are three of them one of them just
has height one it goes up it just zigzag
back forth one of them has height 2 a 3
I mean it goes up and all the way and
then down all the way and and the other
three have high 2 and similarly you can
you can you can figure out how many how
many dick ties have a certain height
like in did not convicted president so I
is 10 well here comes the strange
punchline and that is let's group
together those of height 1 and height 2
and add that together you get 4 8 16 s 0
and then group together the next four
cases Heights three four five and six
and then you group together the next
case with 78 up to up to 14 and in
general you know you're the next eight
cases group these together well it turns
out this is equivalent to the number of
binary trees with a certain stroller
number so so here's my table that I had
before you know like here this number 26
well 18 plus 7 plus 1 is 26 so it's the
long height of a of a group of nessa
parentheses corresponds to straw a
number as well and eff France on points
this out any and he states in his paper
right here at the bottom of this page to
construct a by jection be you know
sufficiently simple between the set of
three binary trees and then you want to
transform the variable rig that the
number maximum number of registers and
the variable logarithm of 1 plus the
height of the of the of you know he
defines this hag function so so he says
this problem is an open problem can't
eat I know it's true but I have no idea
how to how to convert a Vanessa
parentheses with height something's on
the interest into a binary tree whose
drawler number is the logarithm of this
height of 1 plus to hide ok so that's my
second by ejection and I have a program
called France on which which does that
so um so the scholar number then
originated in study of rivers and
naturally you think of a river as a
binary tree because rivers come together
two at a time instead of three at a time
and then computers we have algebraic
Russians but then then the pruning order
was an was natural model in another
another context here we have something
quite different the logarithm of the
height of a pattern of nested
parentheses and it would end so he can
indirect proof which explain why this
was in fact mathematically true but was
looking for a direct way to to find a
rejection between the two concepts of so
here I'm sorry I go to France aw and I
and so here I run through all of the all
of the nested parentheses and and you
know do the construction now I want it
but but this this is a completely
different kind of ejection from the
other one that we had for forest and
it's so I think it's a fundamental I
think that there's their books about
constructive common attacks and and of
nobody has before I commented on the
unremarkable difference between between
two kinds of projections one of which
seems to be going forward and then
backward like this when I make a
recursive construction and then and then
I in in order to in order to get the
inverse by ejection I run time backwards
and I say what led to this and ice and I
and I go from the time for from the end
and unwrap it one step at a time until I
get back to the beginning with this kind
of rejection i'm going to show you now
so there's a zillion there's a zillion
interesting rejections between nested
parentheses and binary trees and I and
the and under post kofsky one of our
former students published this in ACM
journal in nineteen eighty here and
here's the idea so let's take this as a
sample
as a sample nested mr. parentheses end
up how the first step is always up you
can't go down you never supposed to go
negative so the first step has to go up
so has to be done it and the last step
is always down but what but I'm going to
extend it by adding one more step to go
to go down below I so so I sort of take
attaching the first step and put it on
the last it but but now I'm going to I'm
going to build a binary tree as follows
I I imagine that I'm uncovering this
this nested parenthesis 1 one item at a
time first look and said Oh up ok and
down now I'm going to read this from
left to right and and I start out with a
binary with a short sleep i put node 1
its root of the binary tree and ice and
now I I choose a link that i haven't yet
decided whether it exists or not sok sok
right now everything is unknown about
this binary tree except that has a route
1 and so i choose a link that i want to
fill in now and i'm going to choose the
left link of one ok now I now I look at
at the next step of my path oh it's
enough step up step says ok link goes in
down step means don't put a link there
so so uh you know so this is close to
two now I choose another another place
where where I don't know a link i don't
know whether there's a right link here i
don't know if there's a left link from
two or right link from two but take any
anyone that you don't know and and have
some definite deterministic rule for
figuring that out and for example if you
if you always choose the leftmost bottom
most unknown one then you get a
depth-first search and it gives you one
course but i'm going to use breadth
first search
fun bonus I'm going to say ok let's look
at this one next is there a branch here
or not and the next step is bound so
says nope this guy's you know that this
is a leaf nothing there ok now i have
open not now I'm kind I'm going to go
breadth first year so i'm going to go
left to right by levels in this tree and
fill and fill in the links it so the
next step is there a branch from two to
the left no so there's nothing there is
there a branch from two to the right if
if if if I stopped going that would be
the end and I'd be done but it but I
can't stop so I have to go on have to
have to get 15 nodes in here so I'm
going to go up and I'm going to get a 3
now the next step is asked about three
to the left yes for is there a three to
the right five yes it's there five four
to the left nope it's it's not for to
the right nope five to the left yes so
you see how I'm filling this in now the
point is I I'll get a binary tree out of
this and each time and and but now
imagine decoding this binary tree the
interesting thing is the decoding
process also goes left to right that
that I'm not running time backwards what
I'm running time forward to in order to
decode this let's try to figure out what
what nested parenthesis corresponding to
this tree so I start out always I have
the first the first mr. parenthesis has
to go up so now I I look and I say oh
you know I the binary tree let's suppose
I didn't know what the first step was
you know something to look at the left
branch yes it's there so the next step
goes up and look at the right branch is
not there so that means I got to go down
I look at the left branch of two is not
there so I got to go down again
we got the right branch of two is there
so I go up so so here's the kids it's a
different kind of projection time is
running forward in both in both the
encoding and the decoding of the of the
thing and this is these projections are
somewhat rare you know most of most the
time you find a one-to-one
correspondence you you it doesn't work
this way but lo and behold it does it
does work and and and with some time is
running out then worries I've already
been speaking about an hour I can't go
into the details except that there is a
very interesting way very interesting
deterministic rule for determining which
rich link I'm going to be querying at
each step any deterministic rule you
have gives you a wonder one gives you a
badge action I can run this thing
backwards and and and the rule that i
actually have is is one that has the
property that what that the that if i
start out with a nested thing that has
height H where H you know then the the
binary tree that I construct is going to
have a strong number of a log age
basically log of 1 plus age and and
conversely and the way and in the
deterministic rule for deciding who
which link I'm going to investigate next
I I keep track a a little heap of
partial information about sort of the
hot the the items that that that could
possibly be causing complexity of
evaluation of a of an arithmetic
expression and so if you're interested
in seeing how this works again you can
download the program Oh No watch it with
your debugger you could
animated you can check it out on makeup
makeup a binary tree watch it step by
step and you'll see this into this
amazing thing going going and it's a 24
pages long and and involves some
interesting data structure so so this is
a than we've had done you know I said I
could complete a golden triangle of
three of three things that that here i
have the straw a number four rivers here
i have the pruning order for forest and
here i have the log height for nested
pass and these all have the same
statistics there's ways to to correspond
back and forth between these of between
these things like there's no simple
correspondence known from here to here
but but you but you can apply the the
two so as as he and i were talking about
this last year we discovered that
there's yet another a fourth
mathematical concept fairly natural that
has again the same concepts trawler
pruning blood height the same
distribution occurs and so i'm going to
kind of close by mentioning that quickly
and it's 10 is described by what might
my third my third rejection which i
named after vino because it because the
basic idea was due to him and and its
new kind of combinatorial object that
that he was that he would decided to
call kepler towers so let me now explain
to you what a kepler tower is in a
minute and I the kepler tower has a
certain number of walls and it turns out
that the number of and and bricks so it
turns out that the number of Kepler
towers
with n bricks and K walls is exactly the
same as the number of binary trees with
n nodes and straw a number K and
similarly for pruning order and looking
up and so on okay so here's a Kepler
tower now we're viewing this with it
it's a circular tower we're reviewing it
from the top and these black things here
are the bricks the bricks are not to
suck now there's there's to God there's
three walls here the first wall in the
center here has has 3 layers hi and the
second wall has three layers high and
outer wall is five layers hi you see
that and and so end of the the inner
ring here is that is considered at the
base of the wall and then it you know
you're building up bricks on top of each
other the bricks are curved and the idea
is that each brick okay in the first
wall the inner wall there's just it's
divided into two parts the next wall is
divided into four parts and its third
wall is divided into eight parts and so
on and so each of the bricks on the
third well it goes one eighth of the
circumference but slightly more than one
eighth because of so that because if
you're not allowed to put two bricks
next to each other they would interfere
with each other but but that but this
one on the top here is actually resting
on on this one and there's a little
strut that supports this other end bob
says here note two construction workers
in Lego fans the walls also contain
little struts not shown to keep the
bricks of each ring from tipping over so
so mathematically the concept is this on
the on a bottom level of each wall I
force the pattern
that like bottom the bottom level of the
third wall is brick no brick brick brick
brick no brick brick no Burt it's
strictly alternating pattern on the
bottom and and above that a brick just
has to be supported by something below
it so here's the nope now you can
describe that instead of drawing this
picture you can also describe it by the
numbers so so the first wall here has
numbers 1 2 & 2 it means that dick at
the bar on the lower level is in
position one on the next level there's a
brick in position two and and a third
level of brick in position two so that's
your first that that's your first well
the inner wall the next wall has four
slots and on the bottom row it's fixed
force to be 13 then above that is is a
brick at position 4 and and above that
it works at position 1 and 3 the 4
supports of one and the four also
supports a 3 to get support in position
p you have to have a brick in position P
minus 1 or P or P plus 1 on on the level
below you so that's a Kepler tower with
with three walls and and I and here's a
nested paranthesis or and and I have a
correspondence that takes that's
actually very simple runs really fast
and and it's it's son sorry it's a
there's the theory explained here but
but the recording is less than twenty
lines of code or two to find the
correspondence that takes these things
into into Kepler tower and so so here is
a very strange thing we have a
mathematical concept that arises in for
why quite different things and so
there's must be something it must be
something going on and mysteries you
know maybe you know next week we'll
think of yet another way in which these
this concept of strong number appears
and I hope you can see why I thought it
was the most interesting thing I learned
about trees in night in the year two
thousand and five any question you got
question so you mentioned there's an
open palm concerning the intermediate
number for the intermediate pre-op
numbers right now there are also
presumably intermediates trawler numbers
yeah I did the same that I know they
aren't I don't think so but I help you
know that does right so so it's right
that you can you can take a forest and
and you can decorate like I did here you
can put these numbers this is this is
done with pencil instead of penance I'm
not quite so sloppy when I use a pencil
so you so we put this we we annotate
with each each node how long it's going
to survive in the process and if we knew
the distribution you know how many fries
anomaly 2 and so on are you going to
have in this then then that open problem
what we would know how to do it and
similarly we can annotate the rivers
with it with the numbers as we as we saw
now I told you how to add on tape the
rivers it's easy when a binary tree if
you have a cave meeting with the k then
it calls k plus one if you have a que
meeting with a J that unequal you take
the max of J&K and and and a leaf is
zero I mean up belief the the guy at the
bottom is it hasn't has no children has
one and if you have a null branch you
consider that at zero
now but I haven't explained the
annotation of this and that's it and
that's a fairly simple rule how did I
know to put a 3 here so what you do is
you in the forest you look at the
children and you take the max and you
see if the max occurred more than once
or not the max occurred is that only
once then you just pass the max up to
the to the parent but if the max
occurred at least twice then you then
you add 1 and so now it it's it took
similar in flavor to the binary tree
case but but still it required now for
example I asked in preparing last night
when I was when I was getting ready for
this lecture I took this for us and I
took the natural binary tree that
correspond to this forest this this just
says go go to your this is a binary tree
with the tip of this way and so you draw
links to your SIB to your siblings
member to the family are linked by right
links into the first child is left knee
and now now I can say well what forest
woods I'll burgers transformation take
into this guy this this guy happens to
have a happens to have smaller number
two not three up and the answer was this
is the forest that goes in by Zell
burgers to this one and so at the so we
said one is going to be preserved but
then then this B gets shifted down to be
to be a child of three instead of a
sibling of three and then later on it's
going to be shifted down to be a child
of 6 in this correspondence so turned
out this is the forest that corresponds
to this three and it certainly doesn't
like I got you know I got three twos
here and i have 4 20 sided tied atif
are going to are going to say the same
but I think you're right that it's also
an open problem for what are the numbers
in this in the in the binary 3 case for
how how many nodes are of a random
binary tree get a 2 in them for example
I'm okay yeah i'm not sure that so I I
haven't I thought of the problem this
morning just an hour before you did or
you haven't two hours before you did but
it's just a certainly it's certainly a
reasonable question and I don't know if
it's easy I know that this other one
doesn't seem to be easy but this one
might might be do I i I've never seen
that question asked before as to as if
you prune away the one rivers yeah good
question
it was about the binder cheese when they
observe them in river basins or the RNA
structures have they figured out which
ones are more common so so the
geologists are interested in relating
these numbers to the to the qualities of
the rock so that or the terrain for
examples and so they they they study the
the number of bifurcations between
rivers of order 3 that you know the
distribution of the three tubes versus
the three threes and so on thing like
that and they and they try to classify
that and correlate that with proper with
with physical property the the RNA I I'm
not familiar with with what with what
people do with that model but I think
they're they're more interested in
trying to observe um well I mean in both
cases you try to you try to get familiar
with distribution that isn't that isn't
uniform random but you say for example
here I showed you these show you these
trees it's pretty clear that this tree
this is a different species from this
tree and and you know so so so you so
you know I scientist will try to will
try to say say can we can we find out
some differential equations that we
explain this different kinds of stunted
growth or something like this that that
that occur and then maybe use this for
identifying you know finding
similarities or differences between
different populations suggesting
suggesting some and possibly some
evolutionary thing
so the the paper flea illustration I
showed you it was that they were trying
to say that there was just this one is
trying to say that there's actually not
too much difference between ecoli and
yeast and and and they if you disregard
you know filaments or something like
that but but I this is I'm talking only
about pure mathematical concepts here
but the that having having mathematical
tools just gives you sort of more more
curves to your more mental models for
which you can you can attack the messy
of problems of science question that in
mapping these things you're going from
the numbers to the logarithm of the
height and if we're sort of kind of
taking heights and grouping together
yeah other than that them I'm wondering
if if you kind of look at the actual
height yeah and what when you had it go
by like that's something interested I
have a rigged up you know i have a river
that wasn't three but sort of 2.6 or
something like this right and our state
yeah yeah good question interest yeah
that's right so take a look at the this
by jection for example to see if we can
think of a benign injured valued
parameter that that that would come out
of the soul so that you take nasa
practices of high five and and and that
gives you trees that are a little bit
less then than those of high six some in
some sense right yeah d you could you
could say that the but I don't know you
have to speculate
it's 20 um is there any connection
between these types of problems maybe
gamblers ruin type problem I'm resume
yes the the master parentheses is
equivalent to random walk with with an
absorbing barrier for example so you
ruined if you if you lose if you try to
go negative in your capital yeah yeah
and and so ya think of lucky gamblers
love trees and unlucky gamblers hate
trees too
I more questions oh yeah that's right i
forgot one of the jokes i was going to
tell you but i'll save it for next
Christmas